[Music]
how do you deal with high level betrayal
with malicious intent well that's a
that's aggressive so there's a couple
things one
you know I don't recall if like for
example it was funny where my brain went
I'm very anti-litigation so but when I
hear that I'm like you know it's
appropriate for some people that there's
litigation right what I tend to do is
just if it's something structured as
that sentence I just cut out of my life
and cut my losses you know I'm in a
place in my life emotionally and
financially and have been my entire life
even when I didn't have the financial
part where I never choose money for my
own unhappiness and if somebody is
trying to do bad things and then you've
got to decide right like you know if
somebody's trying to
blackmail extort steel like you know
these are you go through the proper
channels and we all have some people
litigate 24 7. some people want to have
conversations directly with the person
some people want to go public with the
information it has to work for Aiden or
whoever here is thinking about those
things how do I
one on you know some of you already know
this my preference is one on one because
because I'm thrilled to do stuff in
public I'm I'm not thrilled to do
litigation but I always find that if
there's a major problem there's actually
a real opportunity to have a real
conversation there's just so valuable
right like and so like being the bigger
person and having a direct combo would
be my first place
often if someone does something so
tough
um
they're in such a bad place that even
the one-on-one can't solve that that
usually then leads to cut out you know
to me if I've given one or two
meaningful tries to salvage a
relationship in the right way and I'm
not being met halfway then I'm
incredibly comfortable with like
cutting out in perpetuity
and even then my cutting out in
perpetuity is like secretly I hope in
four years it could be reconciled
there's just no reason to have pain and
negativity in the world if you can help
it and so that's kind of where I'm at
how do you determine what's going to
retain and employ the longest money
title
human interaction culture their
relationship directly with you if you're
at the top are the themes that create
retention however you don't know that's
the point of Entrepreneurship you don't
know those are the themes
and to the point where the question was
asked having constant conversation
yeah I think another indicator is they
have strong relationships with other
people that are looking to retain
so one thing that's been an indicator
for sure is they have a relationship
with me but they're also tight with two
to six people that have been here for
eight or ten years
yeah thank you for the entertainment
Anthony M
um and so I uh
but you just don't know I you know they
get married
and they need to move to their spouse's
hometown
obviously with remote that's easier now
but you know there's a million things
that go into it all you can do as a
business owner is have the right intent
and that will keep the highest
percentage of people for you how would
you use LinkedIn to transition from one
industry to another by producing videos
and written words and making Decks that
you post in LinkedIn constantly like a
blog post or a social media post
and you speak from a place of your
opinions and your outside Opera
observations
which then positions you as if you have
good ideas thoughtful and somebody with
fresh eyes that might be of interest to
be hired or partnered with my advice is
similar to a person that's trying to
teach physical health Gary how do I get
muscles proper exercise where you're
doing the move properly as someone who
had no chest muscles eight years ago all
of the things I was doing was being done
in my neck and shoulders and I was prone
to injury and you know by doing it right
over a period of time it happened but I
also had to eat protein after I worked
out like you do the right thing same in
business almost every question in
today's society is actually predicated
on putting out content into social
networks but then you also have to do it
properly what strategies would you
implement for small businesses in this
down Market the answer I just gave
earlier like literally a headline I was
thinking about green screening yesterday
was about how a tick tocker did one
review of a restaurant and the
restaurant wasn't a virgin bankruptcy
and now it's quite quadrupled in sales
you know I kind of put the alpha in
something
yesterday or the day before I'm writing
jab jab jab left hook
right and it's because jab jab jab right
hook still gets emails every day from
small businesses and entrepreneurs that
it's helping them and I wrote it seven
eight years ago the the strategies are
not as good as what I can tell you now
about doing a green screen and why or
LinkedIn that so
um small businesses need to create
demand
demand comes from marketing organic
reach and social is the best way a small
business can do marketing because you're
able to get awareness and not have to
pay for it you can't put a full page ad
in a newspaper not pay for it you can't
run a commercial on TV and not pay for
it you can't buy an outdoor billboard
and not pay for it you can't run an
audio ad on a radio station or a podcast
and not pay for it everybody shits on
the algorithms and these platforms you
can [__] open an account on Instagram
Tick Tock or LinkedIn right now post
something pay nothing for the
distribution and change your life it's
crazy I don't understand how people
don't see this so I would say become the
best at social media marketing for your
small business if it's B2B that means
LinkedIn YouTube shorts if it's b2c it
means Tick Tock Instagram YouTube shorts
you've got Twitter you've got Pinterest
for fashion brands and female Centric
businesses you've got long form YouTube
You've Got short-term YouTube form
YouTube with YouTube shorts you've got
Snapchat for youth culture like there's
just a lot of places to Facebook's on
fire both reels and Facebook fan pages
you know how can we leverage nfts and
chat GPT slash AI writing for my clients
I think Chachi could be done from a blog
post and you know media creative output
standpoint content like we were talking
earlier I think for nfts it's too early
I don't think HVAC contractors need to
execute nft
marketing executions for their business
I think it's way too premature it's way
too early it's like HVAC contractors
needing a website in 1995. they didn't
it wasn't going to impact their business
enough yet but as far as chat
um CBG I think you know GPT
I always say cpg because I'm always
saying that term Invader like it's an
incredible technology everyone should be
playing with it because it's the first
preview at scale of like really showing
real AI not the [__] AI that a lot
of people were peddling for the last
half decade and so you know in direct
answer to you there's a lot of blog
posts
that can be written
that they can get the framework for add
you know 20 minutes of time instead of
an hour of time to make the blog post
have meat to it because chatgpt keeps it
a little bit generic and that will be
saved them efficiency if they want to do
a strong local
you know marketing play and try to win
on SCM but even that's a little
far-fetched but it's still at least
worth it for them to start playing with
it how do you scale a company from from
basic basically nothing to be a part of
the list where you mentioned you know
Facebook YouTube Instagram outrageous
levels of talent and patience Facebook
was
four years old when I saw them and was
still like was big but like most of the
world didn't know it four years old on
one of the biggest ideas in the world
almost nobody knew it except for kids in
college and then you have entrepreneurs
that come up with an idea that is not
one of the biggest ideas in the world
and they are always coming to me four
months in saying why am I not here right
and that's not what you're doing but I'm
giving you the answer the answer to your
question is
lots of perfect execution off a really
good idea
and a lot of time for it to happen
what's one new piece of advice for any
20 something year old looking to go
above and beyond knowing what you know
today I you know I would say that not a
lot changes
because the real [__] is universal and
deep
right technology and time changing makes
certain things even more profound you
know the reality is is like the options
for 20 year old is even more real than
it was
when I was making that video right like
I don't even know how it's logical in
any shape or form to be 22 years old and
not follow your dream for at least 24
months it's like almost ridiculously
illogical because at 24 you can go and
get a job and at 22 to 24 you can live
really shitty by having shelter and food
that is not really super profound you
know and so I would just say that things
stay the same but technology has created
more options than ever for the kids and
I just want them to go after it more not
less how you would go about
growing a YouTube channel because
honestly the work is it's a lot of
digging it's a lot of water I think you
have to make it about the personalities
and broader right because it's so Niche
if you want it to be you know I think
you you do what I do right like look at
Wine Library TV it was about wine for
the wine business that's Niche but then
it was also about garyvee Gary
vaynerchuk and then it also became about
like macro thinking you know thoughts of
like patience and hard and so I think
you've got a write a very similar
blueprint yes the thing then about you
then about things that helped you build
your business so it's you know that kind
of stuff
[Music]